We're in the midst
of a great upheaval.
Our culture is moving so fast
in such strange
and unexpected directions
that the world
of the near future
will be a mysterious place
beyond our comprehension.
So remember where you were
when you first heard this,
my friends, for it is
the heralding of a new age.
Psychologists are now saying
it's totally cool
to masturbate at work.
All right?
(cheers and applause)
According...
According to a new report,
the occasional work jerk
or breakroom bean poke
can lead to higher productivity,
decreased aggression,
and if you don't
wash your hands,
there's no better power move
than a slightly sticky
handshake.
(applause)
How about...
That's what that was.
(gruff voice): "I've been doing
a little work in my cubicle."
But that's her voice.
(laughter)
So, comedians,
if this trend becomes a trend,
what's a professional way
to tell your boss
you're going
for some workday self-love?
-(bell dings)
-Al Madrigal.
I'm gonna take a long lunch
in the handicap stall.
-All right.
-(laughter and applause)
All right. Points.
Uh, Clark Duke.
Well, actually, as an actor,
you know, we already have a way
to tell our bosses
that we're doing that.
We just say,
"I'm going to my trailer."
-Yeah, okay. Points.
-(laughter and applause)
Points. Every time,
that's what that means.
Ari.
Uh, on my break,
I'm gonna go out
and flick my coffee bean,
if anyone wants to come.
-All right, points. Points.
-(cheers and applause)